[Musique]
voilà on va d'abord découvrir l'atelier
dé jacques des temps voilà sept quartier
du flon un quartier industriel
transformé en quartier de boutiques
commerciales de boîte de nuit de
restaurants mais dans ce quartier il ya
aussi quelques artistes les derniers des
mohicans qui sont là dans l'atelier
notamment l'atelier de jacques béton
alors la télé jack béton sa
particularité c'est que c'est un vrai
atelier de photographes avec vraiment
toute la panoplie puisqu'il a survécu
aux ag que au début c'était un atelier
en argentique ensuite cette venue du
numérique mais là on trouve vraiment de
quoi faire des reproductions de quoi
stocker de quoi transformer traiter
l'image et c'est ça qui est magnifique
c'est de voir qu'il existe encore des
ateliers comme ça on peut faire de la
prise de vue on peut faire tout le
nécessaire et c'est absolument
magnifique d'être accueilli dans le
studio de jacques b tant que nous
découvrons ici voilà alors jacques on
découvre en atelier derrière l'atelier
ya l'art il ya l'artiste et l'idée de
photographier toute sa vie comme c'est
ton cas est ce que tu peux tu peux nous
dire quel motif qu'elle attention
derrière cet engagement de photographes
ce qui m'a toujours intéressé dans la
photo 7,7 et l'art d'essayer de trouver
la qualité intérieure de quelqu'un que
ce soit à travers des reportages à
travers des portraits
et puis c'est traduire son image alors
on va regarder des images et je suis
venu dans cet atelier il ya quelques
semaines
et comme toujours il ya des images sur
le les tables et il y avait des séries
tu n'y as mais tu connais pas cette
série me tue si j'ai fait ça et puis
j'ai dit mais jamais depuis le temps
mais maintenant il faut montrer tout ça
il faut le partager alors il le fait et
tu le fais mais découvrons les et
essayons de comprendre comment tu as
réussi à les réaliser alors tout de
suite
la première c'est cette georges brassens
c'est dans les années 60 13
à cette époque je devais faire une série
de portraits d'artistes qui passait dans
un grand théâtre à lausanne et georges
brassens était interviewé je n'ai
simplement j'essaie de trouver quelque
chose qui est pas qui est une position
pas habituel de la personne qui se
présente pas dans son image de d'acteurs
si on veut donc je les fait asseoir sur
une chaise et puis pendant qu'il parlait
avec l'interviewer j'essaie de capter un
instant où il ya quelque chose
enfin il me semble quelque chose qui
apparaît de georges brassens qu'on voit
pas habituellement fait lui simplement
en tant qu'être humain merci donc là
c'est un artiste un esprit et ce qui m'a
frappé c'est qu'il n'est pas que 1 et
qu'ils étaient tous ce étonnant et
croquer or au vif comme on dit alors
voici le deuxième
là on a affaire à léo ferré mais avant
la photo ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'artiste j'aimais beaucoup léo ferré
quand il a passé à lausanne
j'essayais de le rencontrer quelle est
la première chose c'est la rencontre
d'essayer d'avoir une relation avec le
avec la personne photographiée lui
paraît la photo am a en même temps elle
vient enfin de compte
donc c'est la règle dans sa loge puis
nous discutons puis voilà je sais que de
nouveau captés un instant qui est pas un
instant posez là tu me racontait que tu
parti en voyage avec lui ensuite c'est
ça non j'ai suivi plusieurs concerts
lors de sa tournée à en suisse et au
delà et a fait accepter possible la
première société se faire oublier d'être
très discret en principe les artistes
n'aime pas sentir la présence de
quelqu'un d'un photographe qu'elle a
pour regarder non je suis la denrière je
suis là pour être avec lui pour
ouais bon parler avec lui et la photo de
nouveau jeudi vient après cette une
c'est une résultante de cette attitude
de respect vis à vis de quelqu'un ça
soit un artiste ou n'importe qui alors
les suivants valent en a fait rage à ada
saint jo dassin joug d'un saint
chanteur je passais tous vous si tout le
monde le connaît tout le monde pense à
lui quand il passe à paris j'ai la
chance y avait d'autres photographes il
a voulu que personne d'autre a entre
dans sa loge
ça c'est après son concert dans sa loge
puisqu'il faible il est détendu il
allume cigare et tout à coup et à
l'éclairage la lampe de d'une sorte de
lampes de chevet donc jamais nous
connaît claire hfr lubie ambiante et
tout à coup il ya cette attitude passée
une photo puis c'est tout mais c'est le
bon moment et un regard sur tout ce qui
est intéressant souci le regard
qu'est-ce qui va se dégager de la
personne est ce qu'il ya un moment de
transformation qui s'opère et non
seulement un espèce de de masques
extérieur qu'est la bourre pour
représenter une image l'achat serait
plutôt pour
qu'est ce qui transparaît de lui plus +
intérieurement
alors ensuite on découvre alors ça serbe
a répliqué qu' à l'époque
donc c'est un musicien de jazz que
beaucoup connaissent cette nouveau dans
les années 70 et dirige les jazz
messengers
j'adorais les jazz messengers et
j'apprends qu'ils passent à lausanne
donc bien sûr
j'ai une grande envie de le
photographier hélas l'époque sur scène
il éclairait les artistes maintenant je
trouve que les éclairages d'artistes
sont très mauvais parce qu'on éclaire un
fond de scène au décor mais plus le plus
l'artiste est là pouvait même
s'approcher s'approcher du batteur alors
que maintenant c'est impossible
on doit rester dans des zones confinées
tandis que là je peux m'approcher
doucement puis de saisir un moment voilà
de ceux de ce musicien de jazz
adloff qui en on n'a même plus besoin de
donner le nom ben alors là de nouveau
c'est à l'occasion d'un vernissage de
choix de peintures balthus le lepad
balthus que vous devez connaître et
qu'on verra après il s'était il était
ami avec des vides bowie donc ça c'est
au cours d'un vernissage et fut un
moment où il est plus à peu retirée de
la foule
j'ai pu les saisir mais disent les
demander la permission rien du tout et
comme j'étais un peu invisible
voilà j'ai pu faire de portrait que
j'aime bien la de david bowie alors ça
c'est plus récent c'est cette année
felli scratch perry qui est un peu le
pape du reggae qu'un peu qui a créé deux
des sons nouveaux à la jamaïque qui a
inspiré bob marley qu'aspirer bob marley
qui lui a fait changer un peu de
sonorités mais là il l'a été on a voulu
qu'ils payent
une paye des rançons à des sous peu avec
la mafia locale donc lui c'en est
refusée il a refusé toute allégeance à
ce commerce là et il a dû incendies sont
sa maison de production passer pour fou
pendant plusieurs années et puis se
sauver de la jamaïque
sinon il risquait la mort donc là cette
année
il habite maintenant à zurich et fait
des tournées dans le monde entier cette
année passée près de lausanne et couvre
hall ce festival
j'ai pu l'attraper dans sa loge un
moment de détente et c'est un petit
bonhomme qui est très sympathique qui
est tout le temps
souriant voilà un instant à la suite et
ça il ya joey starr au cours de ce même
festival
en valais il est entouré joey starr donc
c'est plus difficile de le photographier
car elle est une fondue à l'entracte où
à la fin de centre son tour de chant ici
de ces tee shirt et une foule qui est
compacte autour de lui donc il faut se
faufiler et puis elle ce moment je
trouvais ou leila moment où il est avec
un enfant et regarde il est d'accord il
se fait prendre en photo
il faut un selphy avec lui puis je
trouvais que c'était bien représentatif
de
de l'acteur et du chanteur alors là on a
vu des stars internationales
et puis dans cette sensibilité locale on
voit que ils viennent en suisse donc
c'est des artistes internationaux
mais on a aussi des artistes suisses
incroyable pris dans des moments dont
des moments magiques
alors là c'est balthus juste d'affaires
à balthus balthus pendant longtemps il
refuse toute photo il est très
attractive pas de photos puis vers la
fin de sa vie là il doit voir 93 en joie
ils m'appellent pour photographier son
dernier tableau parce que je crois que
paris match il avait envoyé une photo
par par télex et puis l'a trouvée par
bonne que là je dis mais ça c'est ça
vient de la mauvaise qualité du du fax
pin en temps il faut venir photographier
j'arrive lahoud a son atelier qui était
un lieu très fermé pratiquement personne
entrée et la jav oublié mais flash il
fait noir l'atelier très sent bien
qu'une petite fenêtre rossinière or
pendant que mon assistant lui qui savic
dit on est tout près de château d c'est
donc une bien côté de de rossi d'hyères
pendant un code mes assistants va
chercher s'ils trouvent un photographe
qui va prêter qui va prêter en flash si
c'est possible je suis avec lui je lui
dis eh ben vous êtes d'accord pendant
qu'on attends je vais vous prendre en
photo le vélib si vous voulez elle a
pendant une pub il n'a l'époque c'était
du film si cela pendant douce pause j'ai
pu le faire passer en interne prenant en
photo mais aller simple est assis sur
son fauteuil
d'où il ils contrôlaient toujours
l'avancement de sa peinture parce qu'ils
y voyaient presque plus et là il avait
sa femme est assistante
qui mettait les couleurs et puis qui
fait lui vérifier vérifier l'avancement
de son tableau voilà donc ça aussi c'est
un moment aux balles tu sais un peu
différent puisqu'on le voit d'habitude
alors là on a vu un artiste suisse
et puis on envoie quelques autres plus
brièvement pour avoir une petite touche
c'est une base ou la mise en scène de
théâtre
oui bah ça s'agite peter brook
peter brook et là il y avait 1 2 il est
avec une jeune actrice indienne et il
est en train tout à côté de lui donner
les dernières indications je crois que
c'était avant la tempête la pièce de
shakespeare et toujours ce qui intéresse
en lançant la personne qui est
concentrée qui est bienveillante et qui
donne quelques indications avec beaucoup
de finesse
donc ça c'est une photo que j'aime
beaucoup ça c'est ce que je recherche
est ce qu'il est possible pendant un
moment qui est une transformation juste
pour pour ce concentrer
comment est ce possible alors après bah
oui je vous dirai pourquoi les voyages
au mont athos en turquie saïd rab
relation avec sa lan affero au patro
décorateur jean mono ça fait bientôt
vingt ans qu'il est décédé
ça c'est un
c'était le décorateur de la fête des
vignerons de 64 c'est une fête qui a
lieu chaque 25 ans où il ya vraiment des
milliers de figurants et d'huile or il
avait fait la partie créative
voilà c'était un des grands décorateurs
qui a beaucoup travaillé à genève au
théâtre de poche à la comédie il est là
il est creux qui alors en privé il est
dans son atelier détendue c'est
quelqu'un qui était capable avec ses
mains de faire toutes sortes choisi vous
prenez un papier que c'est il était un
peu et il faisait ici une robe de
princesse avec des morceaux de papier
c'était un extraordinaire décorateur ce
qui nous amène à hugo pratt de le père
de corto maltese est mort à grandvaux et
lui les croquer hudak comment tu l'a
attrapée à la après deux prêts demandant
c'est près de madame et ateliers il y
avait une librairie de bandes dessinées
et c'est un des premiers l'une des
premières librairies qui fut même qu'il
faisait venir les les dessinateurs pour
dédicacer les livres pour une rencontre
avec le public
alors ça j'ai gardé cette photo de lui
là j'ai rien de spécial
alors là on a vu des stars et l'idée
c'est de faire découvrir dans les
quelques minutes qui restent une
sensibilité qui s'applique au delà des
stars qui s'applique à toute personne
difficile d'accès aux toute personne
qu'il s'agit d'autre il s'agit de garder
l'authenticité finalement donc il ya eu
des voyages à travers le monde et on n'a
pas pu bien sûr montrer tout le travail
puisque c'est s'aider des décennies de
d'archivés incroyable au delà du seul
portrait ya toute une série il ya des
nuls architecture ya il ya de la nature
mentorat est magnifique mais on a vu des
des superbes images autres mais qui ont
toujours ce fil rouge du respect de
l'intimité et de la nature donc ça c'est
des gitans c'est les derniers enfin les
derniers c'est à avignon en france il y
avait un quartier gitan qui a qu'eux qui
a été démoli depuis longtemps et là ce
dans le cadre d'un interview radio qu'il
y avait quelques personnes quelques
gitans comme ça qui était très méfiant
c'est un instant aux basques toujours un
instant une photo c'était c'est celle là
c'est la magie de la photo c'est à dire
c'est d'être d'être là sans savoir
d'idées préconçues
je sais pas ce que je veux faire mais je
regarde avant et puis la photo se passe
il a assez tard à prague en 68
une manifestation d'étudiants après
l'entrée des dix russe à prague
il me restait une photo parce que pas
pendant cette manifestation
on m'a embarqué dans un camion de la
police
ils m'ont pris ma pellicule précédent
donc il me restait deux trois images et
la autres membres vous avez près du
château de prague
regardez puis cette femme est de 7
pouces est de nouveau c'est un moment
qui est qui qui m'a paru intéressant
sais pas pourquoi qui ça s'est fait en
dehors de moi alors là on voit le mont
athos accessible en bateau et on a
réussi ce n'était pas facile d'accéder
aux aux moines du mont athos n'était pas
habitué à des photographes pas ou mort à
tort c'est la cellule lieux sacrés de
l'orthodoxie mondiale dont qui atteint 7
dans cette presqu'île y a vingt
monastères
principaux qui représentent chacun un
des pays au monastère russe au monastère
bulgare me lasse les roumains etc qui
avance qui était tombé un peu il y avait
des le monastère russes par exemple avec
deux mille moines à un moment donné et
quand je suis passé il a restait plus
que 10
depuis sa remontée alors tu es qu'est ce
qu'ils font là bas de nous pourquoi le
mont athos parce que toujours cette
question comment est ce possible
d'arriver à un moment une transformation
donc je savais que moi tu aussi près
pays les moines pratiquer la prière du
coeur c'est à dire qu'à travers toutes
sortes de d'activité en jardinant en
faisant de la construisant un bâtiment
il répète sans cesse intérieurement une
parole pour essayer de d'arrêter la
pensée mécanique qui tourna la tête
alors là est ce que cela peut se
traduire cette espèce de de parole
répétitif qui permet d'avoir une
approche beaucoup plus intérieure est-ce
qu'on peut le traduire voilà là j'ai un
moral dans le sens qu'il est concentré
il laissera bateaux qui relient un
monastère à l'autre et il est concentré
sas l'image que j'aime bien parce
qu'elle reflète est ce que je cherche
elle rend va terminer maintenant sur des
images sans commentaire mais qui ont
cette même intention et je crois que tu
as tellement bien l'exprimer ce respect
cette profondeur qu'on peut s'offrir ce
luxe de regarder quelques images sans
paroles sachant qu'elles sont en turquie
chez davies toner puis en afghanistan
avec le bouddha qui a été détruit et les
familles quittent ont accueilli dans un
mariage en pleine nuit on va pas les
commenter on va juste les découvrir on
va pouvoir rêver avec toi imaginé 7
l'iccat s de saisir l'instant réel
authentique
si jacques béton
[Applaudissements]